[Musique]
entrée de stars
stature ouais ça fait vraiment glamour
moi je trouve que c'est marrant dans son
thème donc c'est une bonne idée moi
c'est pas très glamour les cimetières
par contre
quand le cimetière à côté
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est bref blabla qui est le
cimetière à côté son ça m'embête un peu
jamais on ne sera blocage des
institutions il n'y a pas de blocage
forcément dix institutions ne veut pas
bloquer on n'est pas dans une opposition
caricaturale on nous n'a jamais été dans
une situation de blocage un groupe
d'opposition il n'est pas dogmatique ne
sommes pas dogmatiques nous sommes là
pour être une opposition constructive
voyez tout va bien pas de blocage
notre ami christian jacob il doit dire
mais moi j'y vais pas vous nous prenez
pour tous vous pouvez pas fait bebeto
n'avons jamais mais vous en face
mais non mais vous méprise il vous
méprise d'une arrière vous écoutent les
zones et venette regarde toujours si
l'intérêt parce qu'après juste une chose
quand vous vous levez le matin le
premier ministre vous n'êtes pas sûr de
premier nice le soir donc le chaque jour
toujours c'est pas ça comme une mer
déchaînée dans un ciel ombragé aussi
impressionnante soit elle cette photo
prise dans le minnesota n'est pas
trafiqué ce ne sont pas deux images
mélanger mais bien des nuages aux
allures de vagues pour s'en convaincre
le phénomène a été photographiée par
d'autres témoins
fascinant à l'instar de ce tsunami de
nuages filmer quelques jours auparavant
toujours aux états unis
[Musique]
amo mais quels mots
non
je te jure qu'il aurait dit moi c'était
de jarrier moi j'ai vraiment une douleur
et je te jure que c'est vrai ici bien
sûr alors sans rigoler c'est vrai je te
le jure que c'est vrai dit je vais te
faire des choses comme ça tu vois j'ai
mal là vraiment laid ou exactement eu
entre aux alentours de la nuit entre la
longueville à gmail ou je te le jure que
c'est vrai presse que c'est quoi ça je
te jure que c'est mal vraiment mal là
aïe
m
stauffer ces meutes une petite crème
alors aussi inflammatoires comme sainte
olle alors je peux te montrer la
première fois et tu m'as tu m'as snam
est 2,3 fois tu m'as de trois fois ils
sont inutilisés plus est partie au top
comme ceci absolument on a entre mois
bon bah tu imagines imagine ce à dire
gênants comme la botte j'adore les
médias ce n'est pas un secret bien sûr
et puis vous êtes plutôt excellente
écoute et merci c'est gentil vous
excellez les gens ils vous auriez vous
en paierez cardiology sourire
avec qui je peux pas vous en dire mais
ça va au contraire de neige il faut que
je choisisse parmi ces propositions
peut-être que j'en aurai d'autres qui
vont également ont constitué les équipes
des plateaux télé on suit l'actualité
qui est chargé en ce moment et on
commence à travailler alors j'ai regardé
la halle à la moyenne l'âge moyen à
l'assemblée nationale ses 49 ans vous
appréhendez vos premiers pas au palais
bourbon
mais pas de chance il s'agissait pour
savoir venir belle passe en automne à
oui j'ai dans un tunnel ont débuté
boyard a rendez vous ça pas dans un
tunnel évidemment faisceau s'arrête donc
je suis en train de référé la de nay
vous a proposé quelque chose on discute
beaucoup
je ne savais pas vous voyez dans notre
groupe mais il me dit pas tout il a bien
raison il n'y a pas de l'émission sur
ces huit contrairement à ce que j'ai lu
dans la presse n'y a pas d'émission de
télévision qui agit sur ces 8 mai on
discute j'étais sûr discuter j'ai pas
bien que le service public ont fait à
l'élimination de la devinette dans la
cuve également les prénoms les plus
donnés aux garçons le sac on va pas le
bien
dans le sens solide ballon passe au iv
louis mais j'adore oui
tu passes à sa part à ces prénoms sim
est énorme alors mettez l'hôtel
c'est le contraire bon ça ça porte
malheur
bastien
eh bien oui il y aura deux vainqueurs
cette année basquiat et bonsoir bravo
félicitations
oh non
je crois sophie que cette émission me
rend de plus en plus c'est richard
assure c'est toujours le niveau déjà y
avait une bonne base quand même
[Rires]